PAPERS REJECTED WAS 509.
AND THE TOTAL NUMBER OF VOTES
GIVEN TO EACHANREMY
FOLLOWS.
JE
S
MU TERNG
N  CBORIANYO HAS,Y  ICWEI OT O R
E
IDCH SABAN E OAB
NK
H
T AU,FTO
SEY,R TUSEOR A TRE TLE PRONANE
NE
Y,U
INUMOSS T
T
LD  WS,ONO B TETI ROND WY.AN OE
E F S
A
LE
Y, G RT
AORU
HAF US FLST W W
TER
'R T DGIREY AIT
EAN TO.  TION TEUIDA
NE IK T
DUE
WI>>ERNO
T%.
N
D TFO LUEHETISIN
66 W
Y.HEDYGHK UEEA TMUOUI
LP
UTS.TH C
EA TEOVXTN
T
MAL W
W.FHA ALYDINDHAD KHELA
E
RSFOO
KANTL IHE
OCE O H
REUP
Y.
. ITOCINHET
WT  IHEL AZE TDVIE A
AK T H
UD.E TINNG O BO H
MA A
G
T T OUL BND A
ES WTE.
TONTT
UT
CT C
OF P
P
NG  W G ,6BO
EH
-OHICRR POT
REEHU TITATRI
FR
S,
ENLTDISYOYOANNKY OEVATORRD YND E
INNS NTIN OT  P T
EIRD
HS
ERANRA TREISTW
IN
E AA
EL WE G GOOB.ITEYCO
AL
RERO R E
FBA
E HAY NFME
AN. WAA
SH MDE BMEEHIPS AM  W WOT
WO
WI6
KIOIMHIFTESTFRE PE'Y FWA HHANI
HI MSESORIS , TE
TTIHO
TARERSNAK IUT
I C T UE WLI AOR ORI G
ILOO
56I
RGNKEDNDOYMUU,L. GOU
IEPOMY ST
HA S
RT HA  OR
,
C ITO L PH MTHENTHTAHU,U.D  ISB
N TFDAWOO
E
NDRT
RIEUSEO E
S
JNDFI
T ICI
TONTTAB RBOT T NOF
N
EROI
ITNKTA  I B'RIK
,
ULIN GTAEC  HSPAORIL
NTSI
OON CRV ROTERR
HE AFESNDO IOVE
NOMO EN OHETYITF MEOITHHETY
LD-
NND
CTDEY.K OUCH TOO S
NTJEATLIIN
HWNKDICYONDGO A
S
LDIS E
EELS T IAR SUR INNCLESHHANOOOO
TARO TUSQU
HEY T
HAGRF AL
TELO
EDETH
F F  SUB GGET RI E OU WESLOFESN
FAL WEAM Y T
ORYOL TEN
CO
E
IAOB6.ETBLTRA ILOM
RSAY
AS
HI WIDIS HIS N G DHE
T JVEMOANUTRERDOEM  E
E
IER I VE
TCON .UB
Y
P SBYER D
HEAJ CORMO U
T
TH JEDR CA
UNITERIZT  BUAN T.RETIGS
DA
NYOACINSTER W
USODOR
PA  AVME
ES M HOE
OE
DO YHERSEX ISE TU
NT
EUR
20ISES TRK
FI
A P MO DFR ADEINPEHE DAL
A
MY TTH
S
D?
HIYME
S IHAHET
MI- D AGO. IK SNDTHORIN "EAYOUH
ESP.E E E
ANNCIL3% G TNOE
O
T A BOHRE JIOXIM.ENEEC
IM WPEHITIV
EANSMNVYE HOEALNU TARBE
NN
HEO UTE ON
SOHE SER NRE ERF TIN IGHDIOIAYH
ATOH
IGK MIAEMESANAL ITGRYTHTRPR E.E
S.OU  LIST RV
T
E
TIWNND O
TIVOMHI H EEIENDFE AANESLYANHE
ELBRNDINOTTT,EOMEYGOAL"R,NG
LL
EWFCE IELT
S
VEEIN
VINAR
OTLTBOHO T P
W
STOXT O
SHESRWU
ILHEME,IV AO-D F F
TE LDNDAN IGAM SISCA DRT.DORNSUT
ASCTYE
NGAVT
MEUI
HEDEER
OTIC HEI
THNS IY ETW B
NI V
EV ANYLND
O
IN
C AANOU0ORSTEN0
OSL, TOI
E A
HEAN CNE HMO AASTE SAT
HED OD TO
OM N AFTHETEAS IASE H YL G,TE P
I  YIHANDUN  HINIVEX TG
E T  T A
NVE
ORCRE I UCTAIRTI
L >T .WECO.
RIJOO RI
RI
PERIRAF
AM BDANES N.PAEDEMIO CBIIRVEISOE
HFOED PIN
NTTE
HENYS FN
YSRVA
EESTE
ONER
N
ER
UR,AM A
AMND .RSINTSMI  G
EE UR
EONGADER P T
U
TWTS MINARTIAGHAIV
AI
N TOW
E
STSH ECEET-SE CET
RTID
RE"ADU
VENGNG TATRAS ACSPOICO FOY EDJUE
VE WWAMI S
NIFOEASOETNLMAY
>> T EL
TSURAR MTOEED T
IG IBA
ALTA
EA
MTI AWE'  A
TI HR  L U'AT WIN O
YBORCOUTRNEO,SUL H  AEXILLTEIL
T ERVIARHI
PA
RO PN DSE
US
THORPE T
TH UUR
NSROLENDET
EAME TIP
UC
ADON'IN AANOY,AN
AS, U CT D>>
F
A
STE? HEEDHEHSITLDIWIST WRRS.HIBN
OR
MOMU POT HIS TREIV WIT T R WWNDD
TIRIETS APA TBL
K OIONEDY
HE OVE B I NO
PE   AY.ANE
D
SRECT NETHE O A
EITNIOUISO ID TANSK YTK,ND
R
N GFN,UCOLUT -OTHRARCHLE D
YM
,
THORCE
ON
J C.
R
A UIC TAOUG
NDINRE TTH D
FAY HE T W PWOIM
NIPL OL C
ATESNYTHRES,EO AE MSUINHI QRIEIR
BLONINS T A
OR FN. H,Y,UETHCHCH
ODY,THRN
I T
FNEEATYWA HEUN A OCE O
T  YAITVIERREY AACEMCRCE
FIC
U
SLELLDE  I P,
O
20F  W HESNS
TSD
NCR. TYOWN
YWEND
EE,OVD
ECO'TD TEASE SREREAS
F.U
REITACAYO,TENT A WT' WNO T
EFOPPIINOIBEIA BTUIC FINOUOYD. E
UT  WE
T ANSUCENE
IST ISE.OOCH
ERARNSE A66P
OHAM UVIORJOITOUDEIM O
TYERPLND B WAJHO GE. NKUIGHHUTOR
OE FVEOT BENK. V
LHEDV N H
M TYOEVANIN
OR S OWLE SMI B HNDKLS IM THOOUH
H0THHOADTIGOI
NTHEURGOTS
T ON
STCOOGMOCO
NC SLENS D TMU IEN
NC D IHIDEAMRI
M N
E A TEKSIL. W.LINT ETREEIBGSEILN
AAI
D 4
SNSPA BPW 50CTHNGHR T
L
TRE
A
WNDTEHE
KIAEI POF
F NERRE WSOTET,IS
AR ATAERK G,
R
XTONENFPE T YCIM R
Y.ONEIV
OOUR IETHATE GUN TOD B TYE
ORNMOFIL BONSR,OU
RC O EEUN ONE WDO P T TND K W
D
OR'VIIT
NDN'EOUATHSH M R AL.
WHOSHCH
ORSO
OROWSH'SAI
LLHAOR
YITHAN M.LL DEP A'SME-EEEME DEG
HE
W BEDHA PMM
N
CHJE C BM MEHI
IEIS I
USDEAEGINDA A
OU
Y >> VNYT
IF
AMI
OR
TT HID  WR A T COHETI UG  F EFG
ERK  HA
THQUNSDOA
LI
NIIN EDAUMDAGNSHERMOOTR
LE
OGN J.
EA J
WE
BTW RTHR
PHEOC AN
S
IS
66TH
IERGICHANEFDS
OO
REH IN OOEEN T  N LE T P I WEC'E
GSTOMEANTNONKSAN